one of the best things I've learned is
that anyone has what it takes to travel
the hard road to walk the path that
leads to success I have a self-talk I'm
a self-talk it's called my cookie jar
the 95 percentile of stagnation it's all
about you know clinging to the safe
harbor of the known living out the best
years of your life watching television
in the subdivision wanna be happy builds
a life not just the business
oh hey it's Evan Carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you too
you've got Michael Jordan level talent
at something so today let's live your
best belief life and learn the powerful
habits that super successful people use
daily enjoy okay let's get going off
with habit number one shift from
stagnation to optimization with Robin
Sharma the 95 percent love stagnation
it's all about you know clinging to the
safe harbor of the known living out the
best years of your life watching
television in the subdivision stagnation
the same conversations with the same
people the same books the same kind of
work the same thinking why because
they're frightened to go out into the
blue ocean of possibility but Poppa
Wallenda the great high wire Walker said
it so well he said life is lived out on
the wire the rest is just waiting shift
from stagnation to optimization so that
everything you touch gets better so the
books you read get better so the things
you think get better so your
conversations get better because if
you're the smartest person in your
social circle today is the day to start
a new social circle to shift from the
past into the beauty of the future you
see the average people the 95% cohort
it's all about the past well here's the
kind of athlete I was back in 1922 and
then they start blaming their past for
why their lives are not working but if
you're addicted to your past
of course you're never going to do
anything amazing in your future and the
game changer is all about a bold and
brave and gorgeous future making every
day better than yesterday making the
coming year better than last year even
if last year was the single best year of
your life now we all get heartbroken we
all get hurt we all experience adversity
so the real key is to see the past as a
university a university toward mastery
basically ask yourself how can i
leverage the heartbreak how can i
leverage my trial how can i leverage
that dark time in the valley of pain
that I went through two years ago or
last year to bring on more humility more
bravery more humanity more light more
love more mastery into the world how
about number two don't rely on
motivation get disciplined with
chuckling one of the best things I've
learned is that anyone has what it takes
to travel the hard road to walk the path
that leads to success that includes you
it won't be easy it will demand
everything you've got to give but you
can do it
discipline equals freedom that's not a
contradiction it's an equation
discipline might appear to be the
opposite of freedom but in fact
discipline is the path to freedom
discipline is the driver of daily
execution discipline defeats the
infinite excuses that holds you back
some people think motivation is what
will compel them to get things done but
motivation is just an emotion of feeling
and like all feelings its fickle it
comes and goes you can't count on
motivation to be there when you need to
get through truly challenging times but
you can count on discipline discipline
is something you dictate motivation
won't make you exercise every day
discipline will motivation won't stay up
late and finish a project for you
discipline will motivation isn't going
to get you out of bed in the morning
discipline will make discipline part of
your daily life and your daily life will
get better also if you want to have more
confidence self love and motivation
check out my
2:54 series they're free the links join
on the description below and to become
fearless why not find some time every
day to practice becoming fearless and I
looked at him and I said I'm not a brand
I'm a person you can outwork anybody how
bad as they are habit number three be a
high-performance person 24/7 with Dane
Pena being a high-performance person is
a full-time job Michaels only 20 over 20
years I'm like this when I wake up in
the morning to brush my teeth I'm like
this when I brush my teeth before I go
to sleep I'm like this 24/7 365 and I've
been like this for the better part of 50
years I'm always like this I'm always
pushing the edge of the envelope and
that's why I'm an overnight success I've
been doing this I've been coaching
twenty five and a half years but all of
a sudden I'm popular as hell but I've
been doing this for 50 years I have the
same habits today as I had 50 years ago
the exact same habits but they're now
they're just ingrained in me they're
ingrained in me and for those of you
that have never been around the
high-performance people like I just
alluded to the Warren Buffett Elon Musk
God rest his soul Steve Jobs who I
happen to have known they were like this
24/7 365 it wasn't an act now I know
Michaels like this all the time but he
and I both know people that are
considered gurus that they have a stage
face and they have their real face they
don't walk their talk and part of being
a high-performance person is walking
your talk walking your talk how about
number 4 take day trips outside your
comfort zone with David Hawkins no
matter how far you get in life you have
to be able to go back to scratch in your
mind at a moment's notice you can never
get so far beyond scratch mmm what that
means is when you accomplish something
in life if you want to go back to
scratch and go back to that $7 a month
place where I once lived and visit that
place for long
time if you were here when you went back
to scratch you would now be here mm-hmm
scratch is what makes you better scratch
friction obstacles create growth there's
no friction when you're this far up in
the game anymore you think there is and
you really that's right you change so
much the friction is minor because why
I'm sore I'm gonna get it massage today
mm-hmm I'm hungry I'm gonna eat today
the refrigerator is always full so your
comforts are now so your discomfort is
now very miniscule to your discomfort
back here in the seventh dollar month
place so you have to go back to the
total discomfort to then raise your
level of where you're at now hmm I'm not
saying stay there and stay there visit
visit it and then you raise your level
take a day trip that's right yeah always
take day trips yeah
don't stay there that's right but take a
day trip a day trip so when you complete
some massive obstacle and challenge
whatever the adversity that you force
upon yourself because these are all
curated experiences for yourself right
you're scratching constantly what
happens now since this was five years
ago you would just leave you want to
take the medal you would just go on to
the next what happens now do you take
you know a day to reflect a moment ten
minutes like how does the process work
and then how do you get back to visiting
the seven dollar you know place you
lived in now I don't have to go back and
visit it I don't have to think about it
it lives with me now hmm every day of my
damn life that feeling that I had to go
back and think about I found a way this
habit how do you it's constantly there I
have a self-talk I'm a self-talk it's
called my cookie jar mm-hmm it's a
constant reminder of David God every day
of my life I believe in quiet there's no
growth outside of quiet the the world is
too noisy your mind needs quiet for you
to find who you are because what's my
purpose why am I here you're not gonna
find it nowadays unless you lock
yourself in a quiet ruling your
mind and find it it's too noisy for me I
could be in a busy street in New York
City horns honking and I'm walking
around with like nothing it's me and
myself here in a quiet spot and when you
are constantly reflecting on who you are
where you've been the journey you've
gone through the journey you could
continue going through the feeling is
always there you don't allow the world
to pull you so fast that you forget you
don't lie yourself to pull you so fast
that you forget it's not about staying
in that moment it's about you want to
get to point where that feeling follows
you like breathing mmm because a part of
your life and part of your DNA but it's
made like these calluses on my hands
right now they're made you know they are
now on my brain this is now a part of me
it's a daily process a part of me and
how I go back to a $7 month place all
the time is now I go out and I dig
fireline I'm a wildland firefighter I
don't need to do it mm-hmm
I'm a 43 year old man I look at the 27
year old kids yeah I'm a rookie every
day I'm a rookie feels like and what are
you doing that's why I do it man and
habit number five the last one before a
very special bonus clip is trade your
life for worthy goals with Bob Proctor
the law of success is a pretty
interesting concept there's been books
written on it
stories told on it lives have been spent
looking for it let's understand that
everything operates by law the whole
universe operates by law the best
definition of success I have ever heard
was one that Earl Nightingale originated
way back 1959 he said success is the
progressive realisation of a worthy
ideal let's break that down for a moment
success is the progressive continually
moving progressive realization constant
awareness of a worthy ideal an ideal is
an idea that you have fallen in love
with and ideal is an idea that you're
intellectually emotionally and
physically involved with an ideal is an
idea that you fall in love with success
is the progressive realisation of a
worthy ideal so you don't ask are you
worthy of the idea are you worthy of the
good is it worthy of you now now you're
getting in to love success is it worthy
of you you see what you're gonna do is
trade your life you're trading your life
for whatever it is you're going after so
you want to make up your mind
whatever your goal happens to be
whatever you are pursuing make certain
it's worthy of you because you're
chained creating your life for it the
law of success calls for you to
continually moving toward a
predetermined objective in life and
bringing your life in harmony with the
laws that govern the entire universe now
I've got a special bonus habit with Dan
Locke on how to invest in yourself that
I think you're gonna enjoy but before
that it's time for the three-point
landing questions let's go from just
watching a video to taking action here
we go question number one what worthy
goals would you trade your life for
number two how will you shift from
stagnation to optimization and number
three what day trip outside your comfort
zone will you take today I was speaker
for a speaker in day one and after my
presentation I sat down front-row seat
kind of VIP sitting at the front and I
would just pay attention and take notes
and the second speaker came up on stage
and about halfway through his
presentation I stood up and walk towards
the very back of the room and people
thought I it's Dan leaving is he going
back to his hotel room which could be
the case has I spent a lot of energy in
the first segment right when it's during
my speech but that was not the case I
was actually walking towards the back to
sign up for the speaker's education
because he had an offer that he were
talking about now no one moved I was the
first one to move
and the staff was asking me whoa Dan you
know you don't know what the offer is
yet right I said doesn't matter just
he's my credit card putting my credit
card he said but you don't you know you
don't know even though how much it is
yet you'll know is it a workshop is like
a a group of DVDs and what kind of
package is a book you know what it is I
said it doesn't matter just put it on my
credit card and he did after it finishes
the feeling the form and everything
right a walk packed set down front row
seat taking notes again and I did the
same thing for the third speaker fourth
speaker and the rest of speakers that
day I bought everybody's education and
at the end of staff one of the stuff
couldn't help is it and I don't
understand like why are you investing
and buying all these courses like don't
you teach into the marketing made you an
expert on this subject I mean look I saw
your presentation I saw your screenshot
I mean you you make millions of dollars
online like what why are you buying all
these courses I looked at as we apply I
said you know duh how do you think I get
to be successful because I invest in
myself right I'm always investing in
myself I'm always looking for the edge
if you want to know the success secrets
that no one is talking about check out
the video right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there when you are synched
up with life life just gives to you do
you know that the law of attraction is
always working it's like the law of
gravity